enjoying it are you not flabbergast that
you deserve it but that you've had this
length of a career yes
I dreamed about this when I was seven
and I'm doing it at 76. wait you wanted
to be a net you knew you wanted to do it
from the moment I was old enough to
reason why what made you I have no idea
because
your parents are like traditional
Holocaust Survivor Jewish business
people like you should be a doctor a
lawyer yeah like old so why how does a
kid I don't know it was did you see a
plate it was a fight every minute of my
growing up I used I stole a joke from
London Lee I loved London Lee London Lee
for you don't know his whole thing was
he was a rich he was the rich comic
right that was his thing right I think
so yes but I only know one joke what was
the joke I used to sit in a high school
uh I used to dream that I would go home
my parents had moved and left no
forwarding address
that was it that's my joke and you heard
one joke and you went I'm gonna make a
career out of this no I was hoping that
would be true oh you didn't get along
with your parents no were your parents
so your parents weren't supportive they
were not supportive of my being an actor
until I get it I got on TV and then it
was too late because they're Holocaust
Survivors who escaped yes but you know
what I want to say no matter what the
problem is I I have a challenge I am uh
severely dyslexic
I don't care that they didn't know about
dyslexia or my learning challenge or
whatever you have a child you look at
this child and you know instinctively
something is wrong let's figure out what
it is even though we don't know the name
really uh not in that not in that era
but something you look at your child and
you go that child needs help not that
wow what was going on that you think you
needed help like what I couldn't learn I
I so you're bad in school Not only was I
bad at school I'm in the bottom three so
academically in America
so did that make you act out
behaviorally too or in comedy I used
jokes to cover my embarrassment so me
too because I had mental health issues
funnier than me not necessarily I think
mental health issues yes you still do
yes you don't get rid of that is that
part of your OCD OCD is a mental health
issue it is yes OCD is obsessive
compulsive disorder but I come from
somewhat of the same era as you and
there's a stigma parents just didn't do
that are you harboring resentment
because they know what I I used to but I
have done work in order to let it drain
out of my soul but I made a deal with
myself that I would be a completely
different person
as a parent
and that my children it to me could say
anything that was on their mind like
you're for up until now your son going I
don't want to work with you yeah you're
okay with that it's true I kicked him
out of the house he was on his own at
four yeah they're so precocious aren't
they you are also resp the one thing we
know you're a great actor we know you
did the funds and all that but I'm
amazed at what you are uh kind of
responsible for a lot of iconic moments
in business in this business that your
name isn't even really attached to I
don't think uh the movie Rocky would
even be
uh would exist as we know it
[Music]